Once Mog Akari
About 50 lines to 1 minute
Well, I want you to dive in the colon or stay here. It's
good when you find such a big thing in the
water. Maybe I'm really too happy.
It's not a slope.
You
're impressed.
Once you taste it, you
can't sleep.
I'm glad that.
Yeah
[Music] The
name is owner Goko.
It is a woman who dives and picks up the
sea and seaweed
. There is no record that Mr. Yama has been diving in the sea for about 3000 years and fishing.
[Music]
1 The style of diving has not changed at all.  It's the time to catch prey, isn't it? It
's the most common thing that young people don't want to do
because Ame-san isn't about to be a senior nun since he came here, probably because his mother.  When I see my grandma
doing mommy, I have a
very difficult image,
and I wonder if the fun of having joy in such rain-san's inner glasses is the strongest, and I
want to continue this forever.
First of all, I dived from 8:30 in the morning and the underwater glasses and
wet suit fins were restored, but I still carry the bomb on my back and paint it
.
Was working as a photographer in Tokyo. I
was chased by time in Concrete-chan, and
I didn't have much time to relax, but
I felt like I was coexisting with nature.
When the morning response goes up, it's very quick to wake up and go to bed, so it's a great match for people. It
's a strong feeling that it's time for
the sea.